Speaker 1: My friends, it is time for the
Friday mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
If you have something you'd like to say, sometimes
tweets or YouTube comments or Instagram comments
may be included as well.
Don't abuse info at David Pakman dot com.
It's not good for you, and it's not good for
me either.
Let's just jump in with the first message
this one is from Charles.
Charles is writing about the Hunter Biden
laptop, and Charles says, Well, since the
laptop has been deemed real, why don't you
look into it and then say it's not a big deal?
I almost feel bad for the Corkman.
I think that's me.
He goes through his whole life thinking he
is intellectually capable.
David Pakman is the cookman he makes his wife's
boyfriend a Sami after he slays her and thanks
her for the opportunity to watch him and Will
Smith should hand out.
They can be a good support system for each
other.
Both are cooks.
Both of their wives have public relations
with others.
This is the level.
Of people who want to decide who else is intellectually
capable now, as we've said before.
We've talked about the Hunter Biden laptop
story.
The story is filled with misinformation and
also has nothing to do with Joe Biden.
So to the extent that.
The story is a media story.
We've talked about it, but that's about as
far as I'm interested in going with the Hunter
Biden laptop, Polar wrote in and said.
When most people look at David Pakman, they
just see a dude.
When conservatives look at David Pakman, they
somehow detect foreign born Jewish East Coast
urban dweller and most offensively of all
of it, most offensively of all, not at all
an outrage crazed maniac.
Yeah, we are.
You know, I'll talk with other hosts of shows
like mine and we'll talk about kind of like
the tone and tenor of the hate mail and the
antagonistic comments that we get.
And everybody else says to me, they are regularly
shocked by the focus on Judaism in the messages
that I get.
It'd be interesting to talk Sam Seder.
I don't want to speak out of turn, but Sam
has at least suggested that he doesn't get
nearly as much anti-Semitic stuff as I do,
even though Sam is Jewish and I don't know
what that's about.
But in speaking with like Jack Yuga from the
young Turks, we've talked about it also, you
know, he gets stuff based on him being quote
Muslim or Turkish.
And I get a lot of anti-Semitic stuff and
a lot of go back to Mexico, go back to Venezuela
stuff, even though I'm from Argentina.
That's another thing.
And yeah, there's often it's not only about
it's not only about stereotypes, it's also
about ignorance as to to whom do those stereotypes
even apply.
Like, I'm from Argentina.
Why would I go back to Venezuela?
I've never even been there.
Next message is from Rhonda.
Rhonda, says Yadav, speaking of which.
Yeah, David, you do look like maybe you are
Jewish.
I know several Latins that are fair skinned
and look Jewish.
Well, thank you, Rhonda, for defending that.
I could be both Hispanic and Jewish.
Know a lot of people don't know that Argentina
is a very white country.
It's not.
I'm not giving my opinion of whether that's
good or bad.
You know, there's lots of white supremacists
who ended up not Nazi types, who ended up
in Argentina after World War Two and a lot
of Jewish refugees who ended up in Argentina.
I'm just saying there's a lot of what we would
consider white people in Argentina.
That's a fact, not an opinion.
But thank you, Rhonda.
All right.
Into some more substantive stuff, John says.
David, have you thought about adding a co-host
to your show?
Don't get me wrong, I love your show and enjoy
listening to it just like it is.
And I also like the guest host when you're
on vacation like Farran and Jesse.
But I like the young Turks too, because it's
fun listening to multiple hosts bouncing ideas
and opinions off each other on the topic being
discussed.
Just an idea.
So here's the thing with this you can always
change your show.
To be more like a different show, and at one
point in the past, we had not really co-host,
but we would we would sometimes have, you
know, like producers would weigh in or whatever.
Not every show can be the same.
So this show doesn't have co-hosts, and that's
what this show is.
If people only like shows with co-hosts, those
shows exist.
But my view is not every show has to be the
same.
So this show is it's just me giving my thoughts,
and we have callers and we have other things.
There are other shows with co-hosts and no
audience participation.
There are also shows that do a little bit
of both.
Every show is different.
There is a show out there for everyone.
But this is how our show is set up for the
time being.
Nicholas wrote in about the RNC withdrawing
from the Commission on Presidential Debates,
something we talked about previously, as well
as earlier this week.
Nicola said Hear me out, have a debate.
That's just a Democrat and a third party.
Imagine if you had Biden or some Democrat
and Justin Amash debating and just left Republicans
out of it.
The RNC would be like, No, you weren't supposed
to do that, and it would be amazing.
Yeah, I've been thinking about this a lot,
and this even came up on our bonus show discussion
earlier this week about Republicans seemingly
bailing on presidential debates.
The idea of Republicans is to delegitimize
or delegate a mate.
Whoa.
The presidential debates by saying they are
biased and the Commission on Presidential
Debates is Partizan.
And we're just getting out.
And they're imagining, of course, that that
would leave only the Democratic nominee and
that there would just be no debates whatsoever.
It is true that if you had, you know, I've
always said, I want third parties to have
more of a presence in American politics.
If you had a stronger third party candidate
or multiple candidates and the commission
organized legitimate debates where you had
the Democratic nominee, as well as those third
party candidates.
It might make the RNC lose their mind.
That's absolutely true.
The risk, of course, is that because there's
no Republican in the presidential debates,
very few Republicans even watch it.
You have a Democrat with a couple of third
party candidates, and all it serves to do
is to siphon off some voters from the Democratic
candidate to those third party candidates.
So I think it is not a strategy without risk.
It would absolutely trigger Republicans to
be left out, for sure.
It might be to their benefit.
And so I think it has to be thought through
very carefully.
Harb wrote in with an idea for a different
five day workweek.
Now we've been talking a lot about the four
day workweek, the four day workweek.
The idea is you have a four day workweek and
a three day weekend.
Every week you do a little bit of adjustment
of hours, you do a little bit of adjustment
of expectations and you sort of like more
or less get the same amount of work done in
information type, jobs, knowledge, jobs.
This doesn't work when it's about a retail
store being open, as you would in a five day
workweek.
Harb has a different idea, which is a five
day workweek, which is three days on, two
days off, so the weekends move.
And the idea would be you do three 10 hour
days and then you get two days off.
And then you get another three 10 hour days
and then you get two days off, so the two
days off shift throughout the week, it's a
little complicated, but the idea is that you
end up working a little more each year, but
you also have more days off each year, and
this will allow people to have both weekdays
off and weekends off.
I think it's really interesting and there's
a lot of sense in it, and I've heard proposals
like this before.
The difficulty is it does become a nightmare
for child care.
It becomes a nightmare for a lot of different
things where you have to know, OK, if I'm
making a doctor's appointment for six months
in advance, is this the week where I have
Wednesday and Thursday off?
Or is this the week where I have Saturday
and Sunday off?
So there's a lot of complexities to it.
That's not a reason not to do it.
But it seems very difficult to imagine that
the working world at large is going to be
interested in such a proposal.
But I find all of these things super interesting,
Cher wrote in about Dr. Phil.
Now here I have to say I misspoke on the show
last week.
OK?
Cher wrote in and said, Hey David, it is incorrect
to say Dr. Phil isn't a real doctor.
First of all, I didn't say that OK, but I'm
going to read the email as is, and then I'll
issue my correction.
It's incorrect that Dr. Phil isn't a real
doctor.
He has a B.A. in psychology.
He got his master's in experimental psychology
and a Ph.D. in clinical psychology at North
Texas State University.
He stopped renewing his license in 2006.
He is a retired doctor of psychology.
So I wrote, I misremembered Dr. Phil.
Is a psychologist.
He is not a medical doctor and he does not
have an active license.
I wrongly said he was not a psychologist.
I was wrong when I said that in the segment
had nothing to do with Dr. Phil.
Fortunately, it was just sort of like an aside,
but I misspoke.
He is not renewed his license.
He doesn't have an active license.
Hosea wrote in about Rumble, saying, Hey David,
I wanted updates on why you haven't uploaded
videos to rumble recently.
I think it's good to try and grow.
An audience were left wing content is almost
non-existent.
Yeah.
We continue putting up our content on Rumble,
which is the right wing video platform.
There was about a 10 day period where Rumble
wasn't publishing our videos.
There was some kind of glitch.
We didn't stop.
They fixed it.
Now, I don't know how much longer the Rumble
experiment is going to go on.
We only have like a thousand subscribers there
after a couple of months.
It doesn't seem there's a big appetite for
leftwing content on Rumble.
It doesn't really hurt us in any way to leave
the content up.
But we're thinking about, OK, we tried it
and there's not much of an appetite.
Maybe we'll leave the content up.
Maybe we won't.
Lastly, today, Catherine wrote in about my
pillow.
Catherine says, Did you see the Consumer Reports
ratings for my pillow?
The quality is mediocre at best.
I think Consumer Reports really tried to be
nice about it, but they are paid truth tellers.
My mother bought a few about seven years ago.
She was addicted to TV sales pitches and it
was the worst pillow I ever tried to sleep
on.
The lumpiness was annoying and uncomfortable.
It just didn't work for me.
It was nothing more than chopped up foam.
Personally, I love a good quality down pillow.
Yeah.
So two things one, I have never owned any
my pillow products, but many of you have written
in most of you say that they're not good.
Every once in a while, I get an email from
someone says, Guys, I hate Mike Lindell as
much as anybody.
He's a loon.
But the pillows are good.
So conflicting reports generally negative.
I have stopped talking about down pillows
on my show because every time I say I like
a good down pillow, people write in and say,
David, those are cruel.
The goose feathers and the duck feathers,
et cetera.
So Catherine, it's great that you're enjoying
a down pillow.
I no longer talk about my pillows because
it's become too contentious with my own audience.
All right.
You can write in info at David Pakman dot
com, send me your questions, comments, etc..
We have a great bonus show coming up for you
today.
Every day, every day, we do an extra show
for our members.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com.
You'll get instant access to the bonus show.
And you can now gift memberships.
We have a backlog of about 700 people who
want a membership but can't afford one.
You can check out check the box that says
this is a gift and we will give your membership
to someone in need.
Unidentified: We will see you that.